fisher se ha comprometido a adelantar 50
millones de dosis de su vacuna a partir
de este mismo mes de abril y hasta junio
en bruselas cree que así se puede
conseguir el 70 por ciento de europeos
inmunizados ya para el verano estos 50
millones de dosis adelantadas por facer
son aproximadamente el mismo número de
dosis que se había comprometido ians en
la vacuna de johnson and johnson antes
de que ayer anunciada que paralizará la
vacunación de momento a la espera de
analizar los posibles casos de trombos y
también en traslación de su vacuna
además la presenta de la comisión
europea- ausol a afrontar ley en tal y
como comentaba ha anunciado también que
ha comprado 1.800 millones de dosis más
de la vacuna de facer hasta el año 2023
con la esperanza de que se pueda
inmunizar también a los europeos ante
las nuevas variantes o bien en caso de
que sea necesario volverse para
inmunizar este anuncio se produce justo
hoy cuando ya se han producido 100
millones de vacunaciones en la unión
europea
la unión europea quiere a toda costa
acercarse un poquito más a la normalidad
bien con las vacunaciones pero también
facilitando los viajes por ello los
países europeos han dado hoy luz verde
al certificado digital en que una
persona antes de viajar tendrá que
confirmar si ha sido vacunada o bien
tiene un test negativo aún así aún falta
la negociación con el parlamento europeo
para que para el mes de junio ya pueda
entrar en vigor este certificado